Well, today we're going to talk about the
Analytical Engine. We've already got
footage "in the can", as it were, about the
principal people involved in this:
Charles Babbage, Ada Lovelace. The
important thing now, I think, is to just
give you the most general overview about
how this Analytical Engine would have
worked, if only it had ever been built.
At the Ada Lovelace symposium, December
2015; 200th anniversary of her birth; I actually met
up with Stephen Wolfram - of "Wolfram [Language]" and
"Mathematica" fame who has done a very good
blog on Ada Lovelace - computer programmer.
There's also -- you'll see it in the Info
Block again -- a link to all the lectures
given at that 200th Anniversary Symposium.
Last but not least - and it relates to
this picture we're using here - one of the
lectures there was by Sydney Padua, who
is a very, very talented graphic artist.
She turned her attention to actually
researching the Babbage-Lovelace story
and has done the whole thing in a
hilarious comic book. She envisages, as
you see here. Lovelace as this
impossible, detached heroine - but
fearfully bright -
Babbage's faithful assistant. Here's Charles
Babbage: short-tempered, thin-skinned,
exactly like the real Babbage! But, thanks
to Sydney
we're able to actually have a picture
here that I can talk to;  of what the
Analytical Engine will have to look like
should it ever be built. It may get built
but it'll be years - it'll be decades
before it's ever built - because one has
to understand all of Babbage's notation,
in his technical drawings, and that's no
mean feat. Anyway,
Sydney has decoded enough of what must
happen. Here it is - it's fantastic!  This is
the Analytical Engine, as it would have
been. I'll try and interpret this for you
in modern terms. This - sort of - almost
amphitheatre thing - at the end here -
that's the CPU !  This is, as it were, your
Intel chip at the end of this thing. The
whole corridor-looking thing of stuff
behind her, with a proud Babbage
standing beside it,
that's the memory! And if you look more
carefully at this you'll find that the
memory consists of thousands of
positions, each of which can hold a 50
decimal digit number. Binary had not
occurred to mathematicians even,
in the early 19th century - in saying that I
do know that the mathematician
Leibniz was aware of it - but you can
see that even if Babbage had been aware
of it - actually the temptation will be
stick to what you know. "We're here to do
generalized arithmetic and we all know
and understand decimal!" So, yes, it's a
decimal machine - 50 decimal places. Every
time you want one of these numbers
there's an elaborate mechanical way to
fetch it into the CPU and just look at
the CPU itself! If it has got to store
these numbers, temporarily, before it
adds them, or something like that, then
yes, you're going to have yet more of these
50-digit columns, inside here, to hold the
numbers that are in the process of being
processed. Roughly speaking this memory,
for the
machine as designed, was seven metres
long and the whole thing was three metres
high. It's the most enormous thing! Could you
drive this with a handle, by hand? Not a
chance! Little picture here that
Sydney's put in of a  steam engine.
Babbage was going to drive the whole
thing by steam! For those of you who aren't
perhaps up with the history of these things
please remember this is the 1830s and
1840s. Faraday's work on electromagnetism
was just about getting under way. But any
idea of having electric motors and mains
electricity to drive this thing?
Not until at least the end of the 19th
century, turn of the 20th, when this kind
of thing would become possible. So, yeah,
you wanted to drive this thing? The only
option would have been steam. Way
beyond even a gang of humans - to turn
all these cogs. So number one, it says
here, The Store. Do remember that in
English notation, for computers, even as
late as the 40s and 50s we in
the UK used to call it Store. In the US
it was always called "memory" on IBM
machines.  American usage has become
universal. We now call that memory.
Equally very early papers on computing,
in the UK - certainly Babbage - this CPU he
called "The Mill" because you put the
numbers in, you mill 'em om around and you
add and you
subtract them, and whatever. They get, y'know,
know, roughed up and knocked into an
answer. It was called The Mill. So, that's
the only bit of translation you really
need. So, where's the program stored?
Is that
stored in this memory here?
No, it isn't, the idea was that this - the
cards that drove this thing - would be
based on well-established and very
reliable Jacquard loom technology. Jacquard
looms weave [silk and] lace and they are
programmed to get the right pattern in
the lace by having a set of cards that
go over sensing rods. And the sensing
rods, basically, every time they sense a
hole do a stitch at that position.
Roughly speaking. So by putting different
hole patterns on different cards and
having a succession of cards, just like a
succession of instructions in the
program, you could get a beautiful
pattern to appear on your lace machine.
And there were even card punches
available for preparing Jacquard cards,
which I think are roughly about 30
centimetres long. Something like that. So
this was not a flight of fantasy this
was building on existing technology.  You
can go to a Jacquard Lace museum, in
Macclesfield, here in the UK. You can see
all of this in action. You might say "Well,
how do you keep the sequence, then, of the
program instructions on the cards?".  You
sequence them by tying your Jacquard cards
together with binding cords, down the
sides. When you go on to the next card you
don't have to feed it in separately. It's
pulled along in,  by the cords that bind
the sides of all the cards together. This
most amazing machine was Turing
Complete. Now, I've done a video on Turing
Complete and what's the requirements
for Turing Complete?  Number one - you've got
to be able to have an arbitrary amount of memory.
Well, in principle, on this, you could.
Number two - you've got to have a
conditional branch statement. You've got
to [be able to] say "If this piece of data is this
then do that, else do this". Two possible
routes through your program. Amazingly
Babbage's Analytical
Engine has got 'if' statements built into
it. And, going along with that, whichever
way you go on the 'if' statement, might need
you to do, as it were. a 'goto' to a
different instruction. It was all done on
these cards. If you wanted to go to an
instruction ten ahead [of current position] then
the machine had to arrange to just slip ten cards on.
Bump! Bump! Bump! Count to ten, and then "Ding!"
Up would come the sensor rods on the 11th card.
You've done your jump. And as part of being
able to do a jump
why can't you jump back earlier? In other
words, do a loop?
Yes, of course, if you can do an 'if' statement
you can jump backwards. You can do loops.
And this [AE] could, and did, do loops as well.
Was he a complete genius did he realize
what he was doing? Or did he just
accidentally do the right thing?  But this
is the thing remember, the program is not
stored in the same place as the data, as
it would be on a modern von Neumann computer.
They're both in RAM. I mean, great steps are taken
[by the OS] to protect your program from being
over-written once it's known that that's where
the program is. But, in principle, they
both [program and data] sit in the same technology.
Whereas, here, it was moving about with your cards,
shuffling them backwards and forwards,
that caused the jumps and loops. So what
else did this have?  Well, it did have the
ability to store numbers anywhere in
memory so there was a crude
addressing system of sorts. It did have
the ability to read in a number off
so-called 'number cards'. So if you were
to say: "Let's add three plus five"
where are the 3 and the 5 going to come from?
Well, the easy answer would be: "Get
them from number cards". So, you put an
instruction here, in your program, saying
"read next number card" and the number
cards here, which are at number 7 [see figure].
you would read in. And you say: "Ooh! that's
interesting! That's a three!" and you can
then either keep it in the CPU and read
in the next card or, if you wanted to,
optionally, you could store the three and
the five in memory.  Now if you decided
to store
them, and keep them for later, the most
amazing thing had to happen was that you
had to take a copy of what is in the
column here, representing number three
and transfer it to the place in store
where you want to hold it. In other words it's
the data bus: stuff being pulled in and
pushed  back out. And in
typical Victorian style it's not called the
data bus;
it's called the Ingress Axis and the
Egress axis. Now the Ingress Axis was
for reading stuff in from store, memory,
and the Egress Axis was for storing it
back out again. But - and my mouth
dropped open - I mean "How is that
mechanically done?!" And the answer is with
racks and pinions like you've never dreamed
off in your worst nightmares. Because
this is 7 metres long and the only bit
of vacant memory [say] is down at the far end.
You've got to transfer the number 3, seven
metres down to be stored. Just
imagine these cogs and racks going "BRRRRR!!!!"
like mad, and transferring the 3 down to
the far end.  But you could. You can store
the 3; you can store the 5 if you want
to. But you would retain copies in the
CPU and you would add them together. The
addition was done by the barrel
controllers here, that's part of the CPU,
and corresponds very closely to what's
sometimes called the Microprogramming
Level inside a CPU. Again, for those of
you who know about the era when CPUs were
really like 'computers within computers'.
They were easier to program that way
rather than doing hard-core 'close to the
metal' logic. [You] used to have the ability to
be able to write a 'program within a
program' as to how to do an addition,
within the CPU. Now that is the basis on
which this is done. There are sets of
barrels with pegs coming out of them
which, if they rotate around in the right
way and read the two numbers that you
put in, 3 and 5; you call up the
addition barrel which swings around on
lots of levers and says "I am the
addition barrel",
reads off the two numbers - there's
lots of other complex stuff inside there
because it's like an Arithmetic Unit
built in there as well - comes to the
conclusion the answer's 8. And then posts
the answer back out,
optionally, if that's what the program
cards say to do. So it's all kind of
functionally complete there'd be an adder in
there, there'd be a thing for doing subtractions and
so on. But the operations of it are
really very, very well known to us. There
are other things in here called 'variable
cards'. Those really were to stipulate
where things might be stored. You might
have a 'read a number' card but you would
then, optionally,  read a variable card to
discover which location it's to be
stored in - if you want to keep a
permanent copy. So you can imagine that
writing programs for this thing was not
just getting the instructions right but
also realizing that sometimes you
might need to do what we call a STORE
operation in assembler-level programming
Well, that STORE operation required you
to read yet another card from this stack to
find out where to store it.  During the
era where he [Babbage] was in charge of
supervising hand-produced logarithm
tables it was the printing that was always
the problem! Typos crept in! People sent
him flame-notes saying: "I bought your
seven-figure log tables and there's the
following 50 errors!" So he always wanted
his machines, if ever they got built, to have
printers built in at the back. So buried
around at the back of this,
yes, there is a printer that could print
out the answer and make a permanent record.